before
you're going to do uh little dancing
there's a final audio test uh figure you
guys can benefit from this we're doing a
sync test with the live stream
check one two three check one two
three adrian i'm going to give you a
clap
all right do you guys need anything more
from me
you good okay
um
another one another one again
full setup
my dog
did you see me
all righty
uh
oh
that's right
[Music]
sure
[Music]
oh
then
yes
for someone who
anyways thank you
all right
oh
let's go
um
yes
okay
huh
right
uh
hello everyone we're going to begin in
about two minutes please silence your
cell phones
also to any reporters who are listening
in on the live stream
if you would like to request a
one-on-one interview
with the participants in this call we're
going to have representatives from hsi
and 3m
available to talk about this case just
email icemedia and
note your request for a one-on-one
interview
and those will take place after the
conclusion of this press conference
are you guys okay all right great we'll
begin in about
less than two minutes thank you
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and thank you
for joining us today
it is my pleasure to highlight the
critically important investigative work
done by
homeland security investigations to
protect
consumers from potentially harmful and
fraudulent
products through operation stolen
promise
hsi has partnered with the private
sector
to identify and bring to justice those
whose purpose
is to profit off the covet 19 pandemic
this work cannot be done alone alongside
partners like 3m we continue to work to
con
to keep harmful products out of the
stream of commerce
and out of consumers hands
secretary mayorkas it is an honor
to have you here today sir to recognize
this very
important word
thank you very much i'm acting director
johnson
let me also if i may uh recognize
uh pj lechleidner and steve francis
um a bj is the acting executive
associate director and steve francis is
the assistant director of the ipr center
here at ice
first and foremost of course we want to
express
uh that our thoughts and prayers are
with the people of texas
the federal emergency management
administration fema
is very active in addressing uh the
storms there
it has supplied 60 generators to
hospitals water facilities and other
operations
it has provided blankets water meals
for the state to distribute and of
course uh our president of the united
states has approved an emergency
declaration uh for the state
we we trust and hope that people will
take the utmost care of themselves and
if they have
any questions with respect to what
measures they should take
uh we we would ask them and implore them
uh
to email ready.gov look at the
um site there uh and learn
what steps can best protect them uh
and their loved ones uh
i uh i join um acting
vice director johnson in pride in
announcing
uh today that over the last few weeks
homeland security investigations the
criminal investigative arm
of ice has seized over 11 million
counterfeit
n95 respirators intended to be used by
frontline healthcare workers
throughout the nation that includes a
seizure earlier today with special
agents of homeland security
investigations
or hsi as it is commonly known as
seizing
more than one million counterfeit masks
as part of an ongoing investigation
into a criminal enterprise distributing
counterfeit mass throughout
the united states in the past two weeks
hsi has conducted multiple criminal
search warrants
and seized counterfeit mass in
operations conducted in five states from
coast to coast with more enforcement
actions
expected in the coming weeks these
seizures illustrate the ongoing efforts
of hsi
our partner agency within the department
of homeland security family us customs
and border protection
and private industry as a partner in
keeping our communities
and medical staff safe and free from
counterfeit products
thanks to the strong partnership hsi was
able to work quickly
on leads provided by 3m a
legitimate mass manufacturer a household
name
to track down the criminals who put the
lives of hospital workers
and first responders at risk or who take
advantage of our fears
to make a quick buck i must say that
we are at a vulnerable time of course
with a pandemic costing so many lives
and causing so much harm
and that individuals criminals exploit
our vulnerability
for a quick buck is something that we
will continue to aggressively pursue
the seizures of these counterfeit
surgical mass ensures the health and
the health and safety of our frontline
healthcare workers
uh who so bravely combat the pandemic
by preventing them from receiving
inferior personal
protective equipment it also protects
the integrity
of the american economy economy ice and
cbp have been
investigating illegal schemes associated
with the covet 19 response
like the illegal import and sale of
counterfeit ppe
since april of 2020 the mission
is dubbed as acting director johnson
referenced
operation stolen promise
working with cbp more than one thousand
eight hundred shipments of mislabeled
fraudulent
unauthorized or prohibited covet 19 test
kits
personal protective equipment and other
related items have been seized
these actions have kept counterfeit and
substandard goods
out of the supply chain and out of the
hands of the general public
and medical professionals have protected
individuals
businesses and the financial system from
fraud
have ensured the integrity of the online
marketplace
and covet 19 related websites and have
resulted in violators
being held accountable for their
criminal efforts
and to exploit the pandemic
for profit this is why
the men and women of homeland security
investigations
are focused tonight on identifying and
dismantling
these schemes rapidly and effectively
allowing the public to focus on the
health and safety
of our loved ones since the start of the
pandemic
our agents have also been investigating
fraudulent
coronavirus test kits counterfeit items
financial scams and fake medicines
we just implore the public to be aware
of websites or individuals
selling products claiming to prevent
treat
diagnose or cure covet 19.
beware of pharmaceutical product
information
uh with grammatical errors or
misspellings
some in disha that they do not come from
a legitimate
business source and for more information
on coronavirus fraud and tips to avoid
scams
please visit ice.gov
and to report suspected illusive
criminal activity or fraudulent schemes
related to the covet 19 pandemic eve
email covid 19
fraud at dhs.gov
let me again repeat covet 19
fraud at dhs.gov
the last comment i'd like to make is
these seizures
um reflect uh not only
uh the extraordinary investigative work
of hsi personnel uh but let us always be
mindful of the fact
that a caesar seizure is executed at
great risk to the men and women
uh who perform it and i i'm
honored to be the secretary of homeland
security
uh to work uh with the brave men and
women
of our department who are willing to put
their lives at risk
for the safety and security of the
american public with that
acting director johnson perhaps we'll
field some questions
thank you mr secretary um at this time
we'll open it up for questions
uh thank you very much josh gross cbs
news um
how are these respirators getting in the
hands of first responders
and in the public i mean what where
along the line
in the procurement in hospitals is are
people coming in
in contact with someone selling a fake
respirator
i think it varies but steve or pj you
want to
take this
so i just want to reiterate so 3m and
their authorized dealers have a very
secure supply chain
but when people are going outside that
supply chain to procure
3m and 95 respirators they're going
outside the normal practice and they're
identifying these individuals that are
coming into the supply chain and taking
advantage of the kova 19
really the global demand for these 3m
masks
we have several ongoing criminal
investigations and we can't get into the
details as to the specifics
but we're working very closely with 3m
3m is providing us information that's
enabling us to identify
some of these bad actors and these
vendors that are distributing these 3m
masks
um luke barr with abc news uh two
questions
um one where are the masks coming from
and
how dangerous are they and then um mr
secretary
uh the deputy national security adviser
today talked about solarwinds
and you know the actions will be taken
and she said in a few months
can you highlight anything for us so
i'll answer the first part of that
question
uh our initial criminal investigative
findings have
identified excuse me have identified
china as the source
of the counterfeit 3m masks and
i'm sorry look the second part of your
question was
they're extremely dangerous right
they're providing a false sense of
security to our first-line responders
to american consumers so i can't
you know stress how important it is to
ensure that we have the legitimate
3m and 95 mass that are being deployed
to our first responders
so let me um let me if i can address
both
questions that have been posed uh
remember there are
businesses operations that
rely on the supply chain
individuals who might not be able to
otherwise receive a particular supply at
a particular time
uh will look to alternative avenues uh
to obtain masks
and these criminals exploit
those needs and enter the support seek
to enter the supply chain
to address the needs of particular
consumers
in response to your question with
respect to how dangerous the masks are
um what they do and i i think this was
uh uh perfectly
uh articulated is the fact that not only
do they give
a false sense of security but how
dangerous is the unexposed
uh forgiving how dangerous is the
exposed individual
how dangerous is the individual uh
confronting a potential covet 19
infection without any protective gear
and that's how dangerous they are
because they are no utility whatsoever i
think with respect to um
solar winds i'm going to defer to the
deputy national security adviser
this is um as the uh as the national
security adviser
uh articulated uh anne newberger
is on point in coordinating an all of
government effort to this very serious
hack
oh thank you can you elaborate on the
raids themselves are these
masks just sitting in a warehouse how
many people
have been arrested and
charged and exactly how was the
investigation
instigated did 3m raise this or was it
something you guys were seeing
being reported directly to dhs
so we we don't comment on an open
investigation i mean we will say
in this particular instance we were sort
of
given a heads up by 3m and we sort of
you know
ran down and and tracked that to to
conclusion uh but our work is still
underway as we mentioned we've been
investigating
uh or this this stolen promise has been
ongoing since
april so our work continues we don't
want to sort of provide any information
in this forum that could jeopardize
ongoing investigations how about
can you say how many people have been
arrested or charged
you guys have that information
so you know is mr johnson reiterated
it's their ongoing investigations we are
working with the department of justice
so at this time
you know hsi is the criminal
investigative agency we're providing our
findings to the department of justice
and they'll make a determination on the
prosecution of the investigations
because i'm cool for this i will go
ahead
uh i have the other reporters are
sending me questions so i have several
um how has the um the fraud related to
kobe
kobe nike changed through the pandemic
is is masks just the latest
are there other things are beyond tests
and
are you worried about uh fraudulent
vaccine stuff like that
yes it it runs the gamut it's everything
from
the the cares act funding to
masks um you know i think
the entire spectrum pj you wanna
thank you um we've seen the entire
spectrum
uh it started off with uh in april of
2020 with
targeting the fraudsters as it relates
to the trade so the trade and the
finance of the
with the financial schemes uh and then
you know the people trying to prey on
individuals and we've seen that morphed
in into like now fraudulent vaccines
so any avenue where the criminal
enterprises
can basically see an entree to
either make some money or defraud some
individuals is where we're seeing it so
it's across the programmatic spectrum
we're seeing this
across all of our trade programmatic
areas in our illicit finance areas
uh across the spectrum of our
enforcement activity
i think it's also uh if i may um
it's also important to underscore the
fact that there
are trusted partners uh bless you there
are
trusted partners that distribute uh
vaccines
uh there are trusted partners that
manufacture and distribute
legitimate masks and we need to protect
ourselves
it um it has been frequently articulated
this is the best way to beat the
pandemic
wear a mask a distant socially
get vaccinated obviously i think
everyone appreciates the all of
government
leadership that the president has
demonstrated in terms of the vaccination
effort
and the extraordinary ambitions that
he's articulated
we must take the the precautionary
measures
that are incumbent upon us to take to
beat this pandemic and put it behind us
but at the very same time we have to be
wary of illegitimate sources and
illegitimate illegitimate efforts
i have a question that was emailed to us
from colleen long with the associated
press
she asks can you be more specific about
the states where the fraud took place
and can we expect criminal charges
well unfortunately can't comment on open
and ongoing and
criminal investigations but i can say
that there are
multiple multiple states and yes
criminal charges are forthcoming
maybe you have time for one more
question uh sure the um can i ask about
uh the weather
in the in the south um how's that the
cold weather
over the last weekend moving forward
affected fema's ability to get vaccines
into people's hands
or into arms um and uh and
other problems this this weather is is
causing for the agency
well we we uh uh we of course uh know of
the
common consequences of severe weather we
have people
uh that are stranded we have tragically
a number of deaths uh we have facilities
closed including to your a very salient
uh question we have vaccination centers
that are not in operation
right now by reason of the
uh of the weather the extreme weather uh
so it runs the entire
uh gamut uh of ordinary life
and uh emergency uh life in response to
the pandemic
it's a very severe consequence and
that's why
i thought it appropriate to begin my
remarks with both our expression of
thoughts and prayers
for the victims of the extreme weather
and also the cautionary note
to take the care that is needed to
protect oneself and one's loved ones
so thanks for you have a follow-up and
you know is there a threat that
some vaccines may go unused or spoil
um i i really don't have uh that
granularity of information
we're taking all uh steps as well as i
i'm quite confident our state and local
partners are taking
all steps uh to protect vaccines and
their utility
especially in this acute environment
so thank you all very much and again
um my appreciation to the men and women
of homeland security investigations and
our partners who made this possible
thank you
so
you